blake sobbed into a napkin Garrett and
Becca are engaged stuff came out about
my social media and scandals were
addressed live on television it's time
for roses and Rosie get it I'm Blake hi
you guys we are here to recaps Becca who
friends season finale of The
Bachelorette
she chose Jared sorry I didn't give you
a spoiler alert because if you didn't
know that at this point where have you
been
all right let's talk about it everybody
first of all right off the bat how do
you feel about Becca choosing Garrett we
did a poll and I know that a lot of you
were really hoping she choose Blake so
please give me your thoughts this is
what we've cut this is what we're
working with this is what's happening
everything is great they seemed happy
did you think they seemed happy and
after the final rose
we're gonna talk about it but let me
know okay here we go so we are in the
Maldives and Garrett looks ready to go
fishing which as we know fishing is a
big thing for Garrett and Becca it had
been since the first night of the
mansion and man oh man do not drink
every time they mentioned fishing
what do you think that was I think he
was so Becca's family as part of this
episode you guys as they always are on
the finale the Leeds family and I
thought her family was so key here
because one complaint I've had about
Becca in the past couple episodes is I
have not really understood her exact
reasoning and sending people home I need
more from her well her family about to
lay it down so do not drink every time
Becca's family had something to say
tonight did you think that Becca's
family hit the nail on the head and was
it helpful for you in understanding
Becca's decision-making let me know that
guy he's the last Steve under terrible
yeah
conditions also of course Becca's father
came up quite a lot and I'm just gonna
get personal for a minute off the bat
because it's impossible for me not to
but I lost my own father when I was 21
and so I really relate to everything
that Becca was saying this episode that
you want someone who your parents
especially a parent who you can't talk
to about this person would like and
would want for you and you kind of look
for somebody who emulates all the things
that you loved about that parent so I
totally get Rebecca's coming from and I
totally get that that would be on her
mind during this decision-making process
but it's tough because man it really
makes you emotional have you cried with
Becca and I gotta say man do not drink
every time Garrett cried this episode oh
my goodness Garrett with the tears
didn't see it coming we've really only
gotten to know more about Garrett the
last few episodes does it feel that way
did you guys feel that way I thought
Blake was so emotional but both of them
are gear it was a cry yer so Becca's
family we've got Becca's sister better
call Becca's sister with the good hair
she is a curly haired lady remember
Becca said that Leo's hair reminded her
of her sisters I believe her name to be
Emily and she had a lot of opinions and
I liked that about her Emma Emily crap
JC you look it up anyway Becca keeps
saying that Blake and Garrett are so
different and this is what was hard for
me I couldn't tell anymore
drink every time you were confused about
what their differences were luckily
about his family's there to help
Becca's sister oh I wrote down Emily so
I guess it's Emily me it's Garrett and
she really loves him says he is fabulous
but then we got blank Blake arrived
second and Blake looked good you guys I
mean I love a man in a white collar and
Lebanese shirt near a beach it's just a
classic look isn't it and Blake is a
very classic look to him very old-timey
we work so well as a team
Blake says he and Becca are the best
team do not drink every time somebody
talked about being a teammate in this
episode again this is where I was
getting confused Becca says her and
Blake are the best teams more of a
teammate she also says that her and
Garrett are like the best 213 whoo what
team are we playing for I don't know I
think with Garrett he would be a
wonderful father
her sister is really taking the reins
here and helps me out a little bit she
kind of says that like Garrett is silly
and Blake is a teammate I don't know
what do you guys think the differences
were between Garrett and Blake what
really sent Becca into the Garrett
territory let me know this was really
painful Becca that says quote longest
time it I always thought I wouldn't
break she tells her sister that remember
how early on she had connections with
both Blake and Garrett Blake was her
first Madeline Garrett got her first
impression rose and by the way she has
fulfilled that Bachelorette trying to
pick on the guy who got a first
impression Rose first impressions are
everything go with your gut I guess I
don't know but also be able to explain
your God I really wanted to be able to
explain working you I've always thought
I wouldn't break
oh it was like she's thawing and this
was so hard to hear because it had been
Blake force long she was feeling guilty
about having feelings for someone other
than Blake this felt very real to me I
know why her mom was like how would you
feel she didn't pick will you be okay
so Blake is in his head again
[Music]
and has the feeling that Becca's family
is hinting to him that Becca's gonna
pick Garrett like Becca's mom asked him
how he would do if he was sent home you
will be fine either way all right
[ __ ] Blake he cannot talk about Garrett
anymore and he says like that is right
so when it comes in this kind of stuff
that's a curse
that's his bachelor package right in
itself isn't it you can see the promos
now the exciting season premiere of The
Bachelor starts right now
his gut right like that is right so when
it comes to this kind of stuff that's a
curse but it was all wrong Lake the
bachelor do you guys think Blake's gonna
be the bachelor let me know interviewed
Chris Harrison and broke down with him
all the bachelor possibilities Blake
Jason Colton and a couple Dark Horse's
Ben Higgins and Peter cross I know what
Chris had to say at 18 like Blake says
quote Wow did that hurt to hear good
lord that's painful Becca's family keeps
calling Garrett a risk he's a little bit
more of a risk I think again you guys
help me out here did you feel like they
were dancing around some negative things
they wanted to say about Garrett like
they kept calling him kind of silly and
they said that like Blake would support
back on being an independent woman it
felt like maybe they were dancing around
worrying that Garrett wouldn't
intellectually challenged Becka or that
he would be of a different viewpoint
than her and 12 we know how some of that
turned out so we're gonna get into it
[Music]
okay Garrett and Becker swimming with
the dolphins they can be themselves
around each other she can be herself
around me they're 5050
teammates I think I'm so confused
Garrett says I'm on top of the world
right now he's on top of the world
because my B's be greater is this right
I have to look this up I'm having
flashbacks to when Lincoln said the
earth was flat I'm not here for
geography
[Music]
alright intense music is playing with
Jared and Becca I am getting chills I am
liking Garrett because he is very
emotional to fly fishing Oh fly fishing
has come up again don't drink Garrett is
crying again don't drink Becca's dad
comes up again Garrett loves the way
Becca says bag a lunch bag for the kids
what man what he said that he loves the
way she says bag gets me every time
Garrett said man he's good at saying
powerful things he said that he loves
back us so much to uh let her tear my
heart out just make sure that should be
happy I see the appeal of Garrett today
is the last date with Becca now we move
back to Blake and Becca though for their
last time together and I want to take a
moment to just acknowledge Blake's wet
curly hair I like this look I'm Blake
what you guys think if there's the
bachelor we'll see more of it so I made
you something I am NOT here for another
scrapbook these guys aren't what we
making these are they
they can't be I wouldn't want someone to
give me a scrapbook wait no no more
scrapbooks ever on this show instead
look from scroll through somebody's
Instagram Holmes I'm a different type of
memory you need to go through and
evaluate oh okay
cut back to Chris Harrison because this
is a live finale and Chris says I have
been doing this show since the beginning
and I have really never seen anything
like this Wow Chris Wow
did it live up to you guys's
expectations was Blake's departure as
heartbreaking as Chris promised let me
know
honest
compassionate it's the end and Blake is
coming up to Becca telling her how much
he loves her she stops him at first it
sounds good no Becca is dumping Blake
and the nicest nicest dumping maybe ever
because Becca is so freaking nice and
Blake's face is squishing up and so not
she's like it's like you can't but he
doesn't know he can't get those emotions
out until he has a napkin and then he
can cry into the napkin you really
needed a blanket gosh Becca really rubs
some salt in the wound at the end here
because Blake wants answers of course
and she told him there was no exact
moment and that she pictured things with
him for so long I think that we could be
right and we could be partners but I
think that there's just a better fit
perfect and that maybe it was even a
problem that she pictured that proposal
moment with him for so long because it
stopped her from liking other people
well isn't that the point of being in a
relationship but you don't look at other
people I was confused by this what did
you guys think of Becca's reasoning did
you want more understanding for Blake
and did you think Becca's reasoning was
sound let me know Blake says
God been week says quote do it all
better go through all this alone and I
like that cuz it was a little bit of a
breaking of the fourth wall there but
you guys know I love he met like the
aftermath of the show like the media and
everything that would happen and
watching it all back and he did have to
go through it all alone
[Music]
you're not alone Blake we're all here
for you then Blake oh my god do not
drink every time Blake says something
totally heartbreaking mmm he said quote
all I can imagine is how happy she's
going to be whenever she is Blake don't
think about that what are you doing to
yourself why would you do that to
yourself like you're already sobbing
into a piece of cloth don't do that to
yourself don't think about that good
lord and we're live with Blake and Chris
Harrison is letting a silence sit
[Applause]
man that was good that was a good move
Abed Chris he's a probe
he says the tears are flowing all across
America so Blake again wants answers
understandably and she says quote it was
just what was going to be best for me at
the end of this what does that mean I
don't know what that was why wasn't it
like somebody happy I'm losing my mind
over this
[Music]
and they are engaged and they're gonna
be teammates through teammate and
they're gonna drive a minivan and a
minivan filled with orange slices clean
diapers and they're gonna go fly-fishing
in the backyard and Becca even brought
up landing those tomatoes so Becca and
Garrett are gonna do their dads
[Music]
[Music]
everybody know you guys love him I do
tuna he's just been working so hard all
season long and we are still gonna be
here for you on bachelor in paradise
don't worry we're gonna have another
sent to the premiere and I just started
crying into this quesadilla okay and
then we get a little insight into their
happy couple weekends and Garrett
describes them as soon as a woman we
turn on the fire play some games
together I'll just take the time now
some stuff came out about my social
media I was just watching this Becca
Garrett interview the whole time
thinking when will the Instagram thing
get brought up Chris are you gonna bring
the Instagram thing up because it must
be addressed you guys it simply must
it's been hanging over them all season
long even with Garrett's Instagram
apology statement thing so then Garrett
brought it up and good on Garrett I
didn't realize the fact behind a double
tapper like on Instagram here was my
thing what does Garrett stand for now we
know that he said he's learning from the
things that he did he said that Becca
has been teaching him a lot Becca said
that she feels that people should be
allowed to learn and grow especially
after they apologize for things I agree
with that
Garrett acknowledged he liked things
that Becca didn't stand for so what does
he stand for now I need to know Garrett
what do you stand for what are you about
and do you disagree with some things you
stood for before yeah that's what I'm
interested in guys I'm gonna try to find
out the answers for you we are moving in
together we don't
you know where yeah we find out that
Becca and Garrett are going to move in
together that is their next step they
don't have any wedding plans yet but
they're gonna move in together they
don't know where or really necessarily
win so what did you guys think of the
finale Becca kufran season of The
Bachelorette is over are you happy with
her choosing Garrett and with Garrett
and Rebecca's appearance and after the
final rose sometimes AFR's awkward
netfile and Vanessa from Aldi but they
did seem really happy together do you
guys think they're gonna make it are
they going to stay together and of
course because we never stop stopping in
this franchise who do you want for The
Bachelor Jason got so much love after
men tell all
but after after the final rose are you
here for Blake Chris Harrison told me he
thought that this finale would have a
major effect on who people want the bat
sort of be let me know Oh everybody I
just me and where I love hearing from
you guys and talking with you about this
show it just makes me so so fulfilled
and I love sharing this passion with you
thank you for watching with us all
season long on another season both a
bachelor nation show and roses and rose
saying and we will not stop stopping
bachelor in paradise is beginning and we
are going to be covering it so stick
right along with us pull out your palm
tree pull out your mai tai do your thing
mmm
love you all babe